who hurt why don't you guys meet up at
the end I like that good morning believe
nation welcome to gratitude journal live
stream number 32 I have a special guest
with me yes special guests is what I
feel like I said special guest to Alex
who helps to grind the charm dance salsa
he's been on here what's it for you guys
loved him so I brought him back we are
in the new channel this is exciting guys
the first video on the new channel so
here we are so we do this daily we
express three things that we're grateful
for i will share mine Alice for sure his
actually Alex go first so give them the
honor I suppose first then I'll go and
then you guys will go in the live chat
oh let me load up the live chat here oh
I forgot lunch at there we go ok boy
it's a brand new channel right you're
not I'm not ya go buddy guys like I
don't know what man yeah ok let's let's
bring it over to Kate relax there we go
ok um it's important that this is a
daily exercise like brushing your teeth
and flossing your philosophy of T this
is Mental Floss obviously Boston your
face age mikhay haha what's in your
towel maybe tell ya anyway it's a boy
that is daily that's a daily habit with
you doing with me or you do it on your
own make it a daily practice for you the
field of benefits and you have to go one
level deeper you gotta ask yourself why
this is important to you not just lists
three things off if you want to feel the
emotional benefit of it then you got to
ask yourself that one extra question so
we're gonna do ours look at the live
chat you guys watching afterwards leave
in the comments below three things
you're grateful for up first mr. oh hey
guys how's it going I I'm just a
surprise guest here uh so the first
thing that I'm grateful for I'm grateful
for snapchat actually uh because of this
tool I've been able to get better as a
public speaker I've been able to hone in
how I communicate my ideas I a better
storyteller better on camera and I've
been able to because of it have a bigger
reach of my students and I just had a
student yesterday message me and say how
my last week's video on
in courageous inspired her to go out
social dancing for the first time and
even though she was scared she moved
past it because of that video and she
tried and now she loves it and she can't
wait to do more social dancing for salsa
again which is hard for a level one or
two student beginner student to go out
social dancing that can be a lot of
pressure on them today what the i watch
the hand movements oh say you getting
nauseous right now whoa okay okay great
so hand movements ah was pretty intense
ah the second thing I'm grateful for is
the remote starter for my brand new car
uh the reason I'm grateful for that is
because winter is coming and i don't
mean while it's getting chilly it's it's
like 70 degrees right now and uh celsius
yeah okay not fahrenheit yeah there now
be pretty intense right now anyway and
just like it's more about something like
that's a small signifier right a sign of
how far I've come uh in my career that
I'm able to honestly I don't really need
the luxury of that the remote cart you
know ski starter just for me it's like
it's a nice great feature but it's also
like I I've developed enough in my
career that I can get something like
this not that it makes me more fulfilled
necessarily but it's just that says the
second thing I'm griefer and third thing
I'm grateful for is my best friend and
I've known for 20 years name is Michael
yes that I had a really deep
conversation and I realized that because
of him um I am where I am now because of
him because I am where I am now because
of him that makes more sense yeah and so
what I mean by that is when we were
younger I would tease him here you know
little things small things and he would
challenge me on it and he basically
educated me on how you know I should
always just be supportive of my friends
and everyone around me and I shouldn't
make you know I think Spence of others
make humor and so because of that over
the years you know I mean I love this
guy he's gonna be at my wedding uh and
guys are all invited to yeah yeah yeah
we're gonna last me a snapchat
as gratitude sir alex's wedding anyway
so what I'm grateful for is having some
of them for so long that knows me so
that I die uh that knows the real Alex
pretty much everybody actually does to
be honest but that I've grown so much
because of him so I'm just I'm really
grateful for my best friend and that I
that he's still part of my life all
right you should send them this video
after yeah that's letting them okay over
to me I am grateful for new beginnings
I'm liking this new channel we'll see
how it goes this is part of a bigger
thing to wear this video will be
uploaded to my main channel afterwards
uh but I've done this crazy thing and
turned off notifications for every video
except one video a day so we upload 529
videos a day and only one of them is
going to be notified to subscribers I
talk to my YouTube manager having some
other conversations up later today and
it's eat is either a crazy brilliant
thing that's going to be a best practice
or I'm the stupidest youtuber on the
planet so we'll see what happens but I'm
excited for new beginnings and for tryna
debt and see where it goes um I'm
grateful for my trampoline we got a
trampoline over the weekend i was
looking at getting that an exercise bike
or something uh and they started like
five hundred dollars and I wasn't sure I
wanted to commit five hundred dollars to
a to a entry line exercise exercise bike
that I might not use and so we went to
walmart and we picked up trampoline that
i've been using actually said the whole
day yesterday the trampoline i had to
raise my stand-up desk and my calves
were killing so I still feel like I'm I
have liked sea legs like trampoline legs
oh yeah I feel like I need to always be
bouncing mm-hmm should always be
bouncing should be a thing hashtag
always be bouncing so good for that and
I'm grateful for I'm given for J rise to
Jay rises in the chat i know here we're
about to hop on a league of legends game
and answer some business questions after
this uh there's a lot that he's done to
help out but specifically there's one
top 10 video that we have coming out
that i felt could really be in
in one that could really be a special
one that will make people think and I
asked Jay if you wanted to help in
making it is what we had was ok but this
it's just okay it could be like
massively next level game-changing best
video ever of this person and I like
those challenges so JS JS up for helping
out in making that video epic so I'm
excited to see where that goes alright
couple minutes left let's get you guys
see what you get before mohave let's
start this new live stream channel
started let's get this new life channel
started what do you get for today
believe nation I'm grateful for
technical support people who make my
life much easier I like that Zeno one my
talents and that's not an arrogance
thing because everybody has them I'm
just grateful for mine what are your
talent see now we want to know what your
talents are send it up number two seeing
the video I'm currently working on
heading in the right direction I'm
excited by it nice i like being excited
by interesting videos coming up i want
to see this video 3 the departure of my
heading it hasn't left yet but i'm
already grateful for what I know will
eventually happen I love that hate
headaches now you see a headaches all
the time I still do i still get
headaches I get headaches when it's too
hot Alex can't staying because I work in
the fridge like 56 fahrenheit like
something like this eight degrees out
there which means as colder in here
because the only fence is in here like
so 50-something degrees low fifties
fahrenheit brother I matter that is
Celsius I get headaches wind is not
enough light so it's why I work with the
window kind of me but I still need a
better overhead light fixtures when it's
cloudy so I said I used to have a
permission to bring food into school in
high school in grade school to eat cuz i
would i would need salty stuff so i
could bring chips into class and eat eat
chips ah so I feel use a now I feel you
on the headache man hope it's okay J
reyez the aforementioned J reyez 56 subs
of this channel already yes
means I'm excited I have this new tiny
channel that we're going to start
building up 56 subs let's break a
hundred guys how hard it sobs oh I love
it uh thankful for creativity and art
masterpieces for the abundant clear air
that flows through all of our lungs for
every day I'm appreciated blessed to
contribute and do what I love I love
that que el bien good morning everyone
awesome for knowing that your head is
going away what do we pay before number
one scoring 270 on my USMLE step two ck
exam sounds crazy congrats on that and
getting into the perfect residency
program to traveling to orlando this
thursday i'm attending halloween horror
nights and islands of adventure with my
special lady very cool and three
attracting $25,000 from various sources
as and using it to pay off my few debts
and travel to the island of Dominica
Republic against dr congrats man that's
great news Oh see how quickly Melissa
people for being on the time people
being on time to the airport for Orlando
dream trip with my special one I feel
like I feel like Melissa and kale beyond
our BFF feel like there's something
happening there there might be just
something happening there ah Alex Smith
evil is happy there Alex all caps Alex
this is also people for speaking fluent
Creole Creole what's criolla I want to
hear some Creole now what did I knocked
over Haiti it says it's a Creole it's
North America isn't creo Oh reaches in
the house manjeera tha's in the house
much is in the house and you in the
house Adrian in the house I love it okay
guys nine ten we gotta go this guy has
to get back to work go change some lives
through dancing slave driver that's
right I'm not why you Senor we're going
to go to twitch we're gonna play League
of Legends answer your business
questions we'll see you there thank you
guys for the first live stream on this
channel and we'll see you tomorrow
continue to believe belong whatever your
one word is we'll see you soon